أنت تهاجمني سيدي أنت تهينني سيدي لقد
اعتدت علي صورة لذلك الرجل
الذي تحدث معي
هذا الرجل هو
[موسيقى]
لأنه قاطع خطاب المواطنين
لذا كان اللواء أه
هذا اللواء أه أحمد
عسيري هو لواء في
القوات المسلحة السعودية أه حيث
هو كبير المدافعين عن
جرائم الحرب في اليمن
هو له أعني أه في
وقت لاحق اليوم أقصد
ما يفعله هنا نعم بالضبط
ما يفعله هنا لماذا نسمح
بذلك  مجرم حرب يحب أن يتجول
في شوارع بريطانيا
عندما نعلم أن مثل الأمم المتحدة أدانته
قامت لجنتان برلمانيتان
بإدانته أه منظمة العفو أوكسفام أه حقوق الإنسان
يدين الجميع جرائم الحرب في
اليمن هذا الرجل هو
المسؤول عن مثل إخبار الناس
بأنهم  حسنًا ، إنه متورط بشكل مباشر في
ارتكاب جرائم الحرب تلك ،
لقد حاولت للتو أن أضعه قيد
اعتقال المواطن كما تعلم
لأنه مجرم حرب
[موسيقى]
أوه
[أب  وقفة]
[موسيقى]
أوه
[تصفيق]
أنت
[موسيقى]
أوه
أنت